conferencia internacional sobre el
proceso político de Venezuela se está
desarrollando en este Palacio de San
Carlos céntrico en la capital de
Colombia en Bogotá en este lugar se está
desarrollando una reunión entre 20
representantes internacionales que van
de América Latina Norteamérica Europa y
países como Turquía y Sudáfrica esta
Cumbre fue convocada por el presidente
Gustavo Petro y el canciller Álvaro
Leiva con el lema de más democracia pero
sanciones y como ha dicho Petro no es un
papel mediador tampoco es una
sustitución de la mesa de negociación
que se Está celebrando en México entre
el gobierno de Nicolás maduro y la
plataforma unitaria opositora sino que
es una forma de exhortar a las partes
tanto al gobierno como la oposición a
que recuperen esos diálogos que están
congelados desde noviembre la comunidad
internacional le pide a Nicolás Maduro
que fije fecha de elecciones que cuente
con observadores electorales de la Unión
Europea y también que levante la
inhabilitación a ciertos cargos
políticos y libere a los presos
políticos de parte del gobierno de
nicalas maduro se pide que se liberen
los fondos congelados internacionalmente
y se empiecen a levantar las sanciones
Cabe destacar para terminar que en el
día de ayer entró al país a pie como
declaró el líder opositor Juan guaidó y
que al final del día fue trasladado con
un permiso de tránsito del gobierno a
Estados Unidos